herzlich willkommen zurück aus der
sommerpause
wir waren soeben dabei beim schuhmarkt
gebets dem freitagsgebet der muslime in
wiehl bei st gallen
auch hier in der sternstunde philosophie
widmen wir uns heute den islam ein thema
das mir wenn ich ehrlich bin sehr fremd
ist wie der glaube insgesamt zum glück
aber sitzt mir jemand gegenüber dem jahr
fragen beantworten kann
ahmad milad karimi ist muslim mit 13
jahren als afghanistan geflüchtet nach
deutschland wo er heute lebt und
arbeitet
und zwar als professor für islamische
philosophie und theologie er karimi
herzlich willkommen vermutlich geht es
mir wie vielen anderen auch wenn sie das
wort islam hören man denkt unwillkürlich
an fundamentalismus und terror
letzte woche das attentat in barcelona
diese woche die meldung in der schweiz
über ein hassprediger in biel der islam
so scheint es hat ein echtes
imageproblem
wie gehen sie als muslimin damit uns ja
das ist nicht nur der islam deren image
problem hat sondern ich habe ein
imageproblem als einer der der sich als
ein gläubiger versteht als ein
leidenschaftlicher gläubiger muslim und
das alles um den islam herum lässt mich
nicht kalt sondern das bewegt nicht
existenziell dass es gibt das sagen um
nicht ein warum irgendeine religion
sondern es geht um meine religion und
vielleicht ist als eine frage die die
meinen forschen mein leben trägt gerade
was das heißt ein muslim zu sein heute
hier und jetzt und in der tat als frage
und nicht als eine endgültige antwort
ich spielen dann muslimen und es ist
wunderbar sondern was heißt das wenn man
nicht mit dieser religion identifiziert
was hat man das ist ein bisschen preis
zahlt man dafür und was ist überhaupt
davon gewonnen
die werden in dieser stunde sowohl über
die schattenseiten dieser zweitgrößten
wir sprechen aber auch über die schönen
seiten doch zunächst sie haben gesagt
sie seien tief gläubiger muslim woran
glauben sie denn eigentlich ja also die
sache mit dem glauben ist verwandt mit
der philosophie glaube ich weil auch der
glaube eine ursprungs frage ist immer
dann wenn ihr wenn sie mich fragen was
der glaube ich muss erneut nachdenken
was tue ich darf wenn ich da glauben
scheint etwas zu sein wie wer glaubt der
hadert mit gott
wer glaubt dass von der hoffnung
getragen dass nicht alles im leben
sinnlos ist dass auch die scheinbar
sinnlosen die armen die ausgegrenzten
die flüchtigen die die toten einen sinn
haben und nicht einfach so einen sinn
haben sondern das ist meine
verantwortung ist als derjenige der
glaubt ihnen einen sinn zu verleihen
insofern ist gläubig zu sein keine
einfache angelegenheit sondern wer
glaubt der hat auch die verantwortung
für die ganze schöpfung auf sich
genommen
was meinen sie damit die verantwortung
hat es nicht genommen dass nichts was in
dieser dieser welt passiert mir fremd
ist alles unheil und das muss nicht nur
im namen des islams sein bewegt nicht
insofern als dass mein eigenes problem
ist weil ich diese gesamte schöpfung als
etwas gutes erachte als werk gottes
erachte und bin davon betroffen wenn
etwas eben ungerecht ist oder ungerecht
verläuft sie sagten glaube heißt hadern
mit gott hat man glaubt schon dass es
gott gibt aber womit man am 24 es ist
eine sehr interessante frage weil sie
dadurch genau das islamische hervorheben
während man im christlichen sozusagen
gedanken der welt geschichtlich so
verfahren ist dass es so einfach ein
glaubens gefüge gibt und dann gibt es
religionskritiker
denken sie an feuerbach marx und so
weiter
die von außen her so seien die religion
als religion kritisieren
im islamischen kontext ist das etwas
anders insofern als diese kritik
kunststiftung zum glauben gehört also
wenn sie an personen denken via tat der
sein ganzes leben seine ganze großes
werk über das buch der heimsuchung mit
gott hadert gerade weil es einen gott
gibt habe ich mit ihm und nicht weil es
mir leicht machen könntest du sagen es
gibt überhaupt keinen gott dann könnte
ich mir sozusagen etwas zusammen basteln
was auch sehr gut gehen kann
aber gerade weil ich an die existenz
eines guten gütigen gottes glaube wird
mir das leben so schwer gemacht weil ich
sehe dass es ungerechtigkeit denn auf
dieser welt gibt die es nicht geben muss
und geben darf aber diese tradition der
auseinandersetzung mit gott dieses
problem der theodizee ist dass bei uns
eine mit lauter und immer noch nämlich
dass es einen gütigen gott gibt der
allwissend und allmächtig ist ungültig
und trotzdem gibt es in der welt
krankheiten kriege katastrophen leid und
die passt zusammen
das gab seine europäischen tradition
auch in der christlichen tradition
ja genau also als alles wirkt er als als
theodizee wie sie es auch nennen also
eine rechtfertigung gottes weil es darum
geht sein wie kann ich rechtfertigen
aber wenn die islamisch wänden also der
begriff taucht dem islamischen welt
verständnis kaum auf eigentlich gar
nicht sondern man hat ganz andere
wendungen ganz andere formen von dieser
problematik aufgenommen um bin ist ganz
aktuell sehen gerade jetzt gerade im
namen meiner religion passiert etwas
im namen meines wirtes was mit ihm
eigentlich nichts zu tun haben darf also
das ist doch etwas was im kern mein gott
und meine religion betrifft und gerade
da bin ich angesprochen mich selbst zu
fragen was es heißt jemand muslim zu
sein
ich selbst bin nicht gläubig dann können
sie sich das überhaupt vorstellen
es ist nicht gläubig zu sein stellen sie
sich das vor
ja sehr gut kann ich mir das vorstellen
und ich habe auch große achtung vor
ihnen denn sie nicht glauben wenn es
jetzt auch nicht leicht nicht zu glauben
ich bin auch glaube ich ein recht von
denen
die die these vertreten auch derjenige
der nicht glaubt glaubt dann irgendetwas
ich nehme ihn das seien vollkommen apfel
die sagen ich glaube nicht an gott ich
glaube nicht an irgendeine letzte
instanz die alles zum guten führt und
alles herbei gerufen hat das ist wichtig
und ich glaube das ist auch für mich
wichtig als jemanden der glaubt gerade
sie so haben um von ihnen zu lernen wie
es auch leben funktionieren kann wir
leben auch schön sein kann ohne diese
ganze glauben und mich selber auch frage
was ihr sagen denn wie soll ich sagen
ein mehrwert des glaubens wissen sie
also wenn sie mich auch was das genau
das ist die frage
mehrwert angehoben ist dass ich nicht im
grunde getragen sie von einer letzten
unendlichkeit von etwas was was auch
mein leben übertrifft der auch mich und
meine ganzen sorgen und meine ganze
endlichkeit auch trägt diese letzte der
mit dieser ruf im koran heißt es ich
höre den ruf des rufenden wenn er mich
anruft und dieser ruf nach gott der
nicht gegenständlich vor mir ist aber
mir nahe ist als mir selbst das ist eine
wenn sie das konzept als eine strategie
um mit seiner endlichkeit umgehend zu
dürfen
das ist das was mich trägt sie schreiben
in ihrem buch osama bin laden schläft
bei den fristen muss auch ihre biografie
erläutern kommt dieser satz der mir
nicht mehr aus dem kopf geht
und der heißt wer glaubt ist ein
flüchtling
was meinen sie damit
ja wer glaubt der techniken zu hause
weil er weiß dass ein reisender ist die
welt ist etwas oder sagen wir das in der
welt sein dass wir überhaupt hier sein
dürfen
das ist eine gabe das ist ein geschenk
das ist etwas was mir nicht gehört
sondern mir anvertraut wurde und dieses
anvertraut werden aber einem nicht
gehören
er sagt dass ich mit verantwortung mit
dem was mir anvertraut wurde umgehe
aber mich selbst irgendwie irgendwas zu
hause fühle weil ich nicht einfach jetzt
mich als flüchtling fühle weil ich zum
flüchtlingen werde durch irgendwelche
politischen ereignissen sondern weil ich
einfach im grunde derjenige bin der
nirgendwo zu hause ist und der glaube
ist dann die sehnsucht nach der heimat
ja genau ihn zutiefst romantische idee
die schlegel glaube ich 100 prozent
verstehen will dass meine dieser satz
hat deswegen auch so eine kraft weile
aus ihrem mund kommt und sie selbst eine
eine geschichte der flucht sind also ich
haben sie mussten mit 13 jahren als
kabul als afghanistan fliehen in mit
vielen umwegen über über indien neu
delhi über moskau vielleicht können sie
kurz erzählen was was da passiert ist
und was dieses ereignis diese flucht mit
ihnen gemacht hat auf jeden fall alles
also ich wäre nicht der der ich jetzt
bin wenn ich nicht einen flüchtling
gewesen bin und ich erfahre auch jetzt
erneut dass ich eigentlich die flucht
nicht jetzt abgeschlossen habe sondern
die flucht ist etwas was eigentlich nie
endet das hat mich meine flucht
sozusagen gelehrt dass nicht erst dann
wenn wir nach deutschland angekommen
sind auch angekommen sind sie dann die
flucht erst in deutschland beginnt der
sind davon was es heißt ein flüchtling
zu sein und dann während der flucht ist
man in einen rausch des fliegens also
man muss einfach ist ein leben retten
und wir mussten wirklich fliehen aus
kabul aus afghanistan
anfang der 90er jahre und dann eine
odyssee durch die weltgeschichte gemacht
hatte von von indien bis muskel und
klacks sein bis nach deutschland von
schleppern und schleusern umgeben
die uns oft auch verraten haben das geld
genommen haben einfach verschwunden sind
und man steht immer wieder vor dem
nichts
und gerade diese diese diesem moment der
hoffnungslosigkeit der sie alles
verloren haben ohne dafür die schuld zu
tragen wer waren wir dann einfach
normale menschen kaputt und da da habe
ich glaube ich mit 13 jahren den
tieferen sinn des glaubens gespürt der
sowohl süß ist bei dem hoffnung
gespendet als auch bitter ist weil
gerade ihre faktische dasein betrifft
und sie können dich das nicht erklären
und aus dieser betroffenheit zum leben
erweckt so was wie eine nichte so nennen
darf eine gesunde haltung zum glauben
dass der glaube nicht als eine art
rosarotes lang umgreifende raum ist wo
ich einfach nicht zurückziehen kann und
alles gut ist sondern der glaube ist
etwas was gerade die beiden also doppel
würdig ist du mich gerade nicht ruhen
lässt sondern diese unruhe in mir
wachsen lässt daher ist die flucht etwas
ganz prägendes und sie sagen sie sind
dankbar dass das passiert ist auch
wieder aus diesem glauben heraus ja alle
die erfahrungen müssen sie die die idee
die mich heimgesucht haben die hätte ich
nie erleben können meine existenz wäre
nicht gefüllt von all dem schmerz und
all diese tiefen betroffenheiten ohne
diese flucht ich kann es insofern als
dankbar sein annehmen weil wenn ich
jetzt mit flüchtlingen spreche mit den
umgang pflegen
ich verstehe sie viel besser wir sind
die flüchtlingsheime sind für mich eine
art heimat ich verstehe sie voll und
ganz was es heißt hier zu sein mit
welcher bedürftigkeit sie hierher kommen
wonach sie eigentlich suchen das ist
weder ruhm noch geld noch macht all das
was ein kapitalistischer
konsumgesellschaft eigentlich hervorhebt
sondern das ist einfach nur so haben
dass die kinder einfach eine schule
besuchen können ganz einfach im primären
werten die die wir hier zum glück jetzt
seid vielleicht 50 jahren oder noch
länger hier haben
vielleicht auch nicht mehr so schätzen
weil wir so gewöhnlich ist jeder mensch
ist doch frei und sie haben es vom
flüchtling zum zum professor angeschafft
letztlich viele andere immigranten
schaffen das nicht die fühlen sich ohne
hoffnung ohne perspektive radikalisieren
sich vielleicht dann auch warum hat es
bei ihm geklappt warum scheitern andere
das kann ich kaum glaublich kausal
erklären aber es gibt schon momente die
die erklärlich sind einmal ist das
elternhaus meine familie meine eltern
die mich ja gefördert haben für sie über
bildung sehr wichtig also sie haben mir
mein vater hat mir nicht erlaubt einen
nebenjob zu haben während der schule
sondern sein ansatz war
ich will dass du lernst mit dem wenigen
was wir dir breiten können das soll
ausreichend sein aber ich will von dir
dass du dein bestes gibst einbildung ist
die rettung aus der flucht und nicht
reichtum oder so etwas
das war sehr wichtig sehr prägend auf
der anderen seite ist mein leben geprägt
von dankbarkeit und wir sind immer
leerer
hinter jedem erfolgreichen migranten
steckt ein lehrer oder eine lehrerin
das können sie mir glauben es nachprüfen
es waren meine meine lehrerin lehrerin
von der hauptschule in deutschland bis
zum berufsfachschule realschule
gymnasium mein zimmer dieser engel die
in mir mehr gesehen haben als einfach
ein ausländer der gerade auf eine
hauptschule ohne ein wort deutsch oder
englisch zu können
da sitzt und nichts versteht sie haben
mich angeschaut und sie haben vielleicht
diese sehnsucht gesehen er will mehr er
ist mehr als einfach nur ein ausländer
zu sein und dann haben sie auch ihre
eigene aufgabe lehrerin leder zu sein
besser verstanden dass sie mehr mehr
gegeben haben als sie mussten als das
wofür sie bezahlt wurden und diese mehr
ist mehr menschlichkeit wissen sie denn
ich habe von ihnen kein geld bekommen
sondern ich habe von ihren zeit bekommen
sie haben mir aus ihren eigenen privaten
benötigen bücher geschenkt sind am
beispiel der abendländischen weisheiten
das war habe ich ihr erstes buch auf
deutsch ja genau mein einziges buch das
ich hatte ein kleines büchlein und
pädagogisch sehr schlecht gemacht
eigentlich eine aneinanderreihung der
zitate von thales bis
bis 8 und die sie ich habe sie gelesen
ich habe die kaum verstanden nicht also
nicht mal richtig ausgesprochen und wann
ist mein einziges buch war jahrelang ich
habe so lange sachen gelesen bis ich
eigentlich nahezu alles auswendig konnte
und als hofnarr im schulhof dann galt
man hat mir ein wort gegeben und ich
konnte dazu einfach ein zitat von
irgendeinem für den ofen sein ohne zu
wissen was es heißt nur der seltsamen
bis dann passieren dass mein deutlich
verbesserte meter zeit mit der räder so
viel mit diesen weisheiten haben sie
deutsch gelernt und alles war in mir die
verstanden werden wollte so hat mich das
abendland in seinen bann gezogen
das thema flucht ist eigentlich auch
sehr zentral für den ganzen bislang war
die ganze zeitrechnung beginnt mit der
flucht von mohammed von mekka nach
medina 600 im jahr 622 wer war dieser
mohammed eigentlich ja wer war er war
eigentlich ein flüchtling plötzlich auch
also darin zeigt sich das aber auch
einnehmen der von einer tiefen sehnsucht
davon geprägt war
nach einer nach einem schlechten
verfügbaren etwas was ja nicht benennen
konnte aber danach sich gesehnt hat
jemand der weise war man dann voll weise
von seinen großeltern und dann später
von seinem onkel adoptiert wurde
er war nicht mehr wahr schrift unkundig
aber womit er berühmt war schon in mekka
war seine ehrlichkeit seine seinen sinn
für gerechtigkeit den beinamen amin
bekommen also in der der gerichte ist
jemand maß an vertrauen kleine
streitigkeiten bundesrat geführt so eine
persönlichkeit wird dann nach der
islamischen tradierung muss man
systemimmanent sagen als der gesandte
gottes erwählt folgert er kann es kaum
verstehen
er kann damit gar nicht umgehen er
zweifelt daran
und mit der zeit muss es doch annehmen
dass das ist was an ihm geschieht
worüber er selbst nicht verfügt die
erzählung ist der engel gabriel
erscheint
offenbart ihm gewisse suren des korans
die heute in courage tja er fliegt
zurückgezogenheit für eine bestimmte
zeit vom berg
ja und da hat er sich einfach in einen
berg höhle hat er lange zeit einfach in
die stille verbracht und dort soll ihnen
der engel erschienen sein engel gabriel
der ihn erschüttert und verlangt dass
herr vortragen sondern er weiß nicht was
er vortragen soll erdrückten so sehr an
fest dass er fast sein leben verliert
und dann trägt ja vor und das ist die
allererste ersten verse des koran ist
michael ballack vor im namen seines
herren der schouw und und damit beginnt
die islamische lausanne dass das
islamische überhaupt mit ihm aber
interessant ist seine figur schon
insofern als er nicht als die
personalisierte inkarnation gutes
auftritt ich sage jesus zum beispiel
oder dass das ohnehin sondern auch
überhaupt als jemand der auserwählt
wurde könnte man meinen dass der artist
an der b auftritt diese geste anders
sein könnte
dann erst durch und durch von demut
getragen und diese demut diesem
amerikanische demut ist etwas was für
die für das glaubensverständnis der
muslime unglaublich wichtig ist aber er
war ja auch ein feldherr eigentlich ein
politischer führer ein aggregat geführt
also das muss man auch sagen also das
muss man sagen aber das muss man es auch
historisch sehen also dass der krieg
führe einfach stand glaube ich nicht
sehr viel vom krieg aber auf jeden fall
war er als der gesandte gottes wenn
kriege waren wir schlachten da waren bei
auch präsent das gehört zu so islam
schön durch sein geschichte die musst du
nicht einfach auf der arabischen
halbinsel im 17 jahrhundert die ganze
konstellation und verstehen warum
eigentlich mekka leben konnte er war
verfolgt das war eine kleine gruppe die
machthaber in mekka wollten dass er weg
ist man wollte sie ermorden also die
ganze gemeinde ermorden ihn auch er
flieht gerade so aus mekka nach medina
und dort ist kann er wirklich das
hervorbringen
von er meint getragen zu sein nämlich
eine seine religion entfalten und
dadurch auch weil wir andere konzepte
von heutigen staaten haben auch etwas
wie auch eine gemeinde führer in
politischen profanen sinja und hast
diesen offenbarungen über diese 22 jahre
entstand das herzstück des islam nämlich
der koran
sie selbst haben den koran ins deutsche
übersetzt vor einigen ja es gibt schon
einige deutsche übersetzung warum haben
sie den koran noch mal aus dem
arabischen ins deutsche übersetzt ja
weil jede übersetzung müssen sie auch
ein selbst übersetzung ist also so etwas
wie selbstverständigung und mir war
wichtig etwas ins deutsche software
deutsche zu bringen was was sagen die
sonst verloren geht in den übersetzungen
und zwar das ist die der klang der
sprache die formsprache könnte man es
philosophie sagen also etwas wie nicht
nur was gesagt werden wie etwas gesagt
wird was dort stimmt und der koran ist
ja ein unglaublicher melodischer
rhythmischer lyrischer text voller
voller klang voller rhythmus voller
voller spannungen und das alles ging
verloren in den anderen übersetzungen
außer lieber selbst zum teil übersetzung
von friedrich hat eben dann romantiker
und da war mir wichtig gerade da es
auszuprobieren wie ob es gelingen kann
gerade das zu übersetzen was ein nicht
kaum übersetzbar ist sie müssen sich
vorstellen
ich sah es dann dort und habe nicht den
koran lesen über 17 hörend übersetzt
ich habe die suche so lange gehört eine
kleine summe bis die suche durch mich
hindurch drang und dann versuchte gerade
aus dieser atmosphäre heraus dass
deutsche autos sind ähnlich es ist nicht
leicht ich bin glaube ich nicht durch
gescheitert sind so momente die sie dann
durch gelungen sind und das waren die
wahren wert für diesen fall sozusagen
nach der koran ist eben kein reiner text
welche setzt ablesen kann sondern dass
poesie das ist die
ich tue das ist gesang vielleicht auch
sie haben hier den persönlichen koran
noch mitgebracht den sie auf der flucht
gefunden haben
am flughafen in moskau mich würde
interessieren ob sie uns eine kleine
kostprobe geben könnten wie das klingt
werden den koran sehr gern
das schöne ist nun dafür muss ich nicht
was im koran aufschlag aber ein ganz
kleiner kleinen vers
[Musik]
man hat ja das ist die 112 die suche ich
spreche dies einer ein ewig rainer nicht
hat er gezeigt und gezeugt hat ihn
keiner und ich stimme gleich ist einer
meiner eigenen kann man das auch anders
singen woher haben sie jetzt diese diese
ton form genau es gibt natürlich
unterschrieben also schulen der der
rezitationen der koran wird so ganz
peinlich genau rezitiert und es gibt
auch sagen regeln der rezitationen wann
man eine dosierung machen soll man nicht
als doppelungen man ist nah saniert
werden soll aber auch vom klang und von
von der von der abwehr des vortragen das
ist ganz unterschiedlich die sind
besuchen können sie ganz anders hören
oder sehen wir da in einem atemzug oder
dann ganz groß also so lula hat allahu
salami alle to a new york geboren hat
sie merken die luft zittert bei diesen
wenn bei dem anderen ist tragen reiche
schwingen so zu sein aber hier haben sie
eine die wucht des unendlichen hören sie
da spricht ist ein
man merkt schon sehen sie geraten ins
schwärmen das ist wie sagen nach der
islam die religion der schönheit
es gibt einen in deutschland der sieht
das ganz anders und zwar haben jetzt
abdel-samad ein islamkritiker selbst
politologe als ägypten sein vater war
immer war bei der muslim-bruderschaft
dann für ihn ist er sie zum islam die
wurzeln eigentlich von vom haus von
intoleranz vergleich der saison mit dem
faschismus in diesem buch hier ist ein
streitgespräch mit einem kollegen von
ihnen und hamed abdel-samad war zu gast
hier bei meinem kollegen norbert
bischofberger vor drei jahren in der
sternstunde religion wir schauen uns
kurz an wasser zum koran und zu mohammed
zu sagen wir wenn wir lesen dass er an
einem tag 600 wehrlose juden in taugten
ließ enthaupten ließ deren frauen
versklavt und die kinder auch dieses
leute nehmen den propheten alles ein
vorbild wenn wie im koran lesen dass
gott den sie barmherzig nennen
25 mal direkt tötungsbefehl an die
gläubigen muslime an unglauben direkte
tötungsbefehl tötet sie enthauptet sie
verstümmelt sie dann kann man nicht
sagen das hat doch mit dem islam nichts
zu tun oder die ss leute haben den koran
falsch verstanden
sie beziehen ihre legitimation direkt
aus der bürger dafür des propheten und
aus dem koran
was sagen sie dazu so geben sie mich
interessiert was mein kollege dagegen
gesagt hätte ja interessanterweise hören
sie wie er selbst damit umgeht nicht
also der kabelsalat hat dieselbe
hermeneutik wie die ss leute wie er
selber auch vorliegt denn was heißt dass
er geht direkt in den koran hinein
direkt in die propheten geschichte und
daraus zitierte ohne kritisches
bewusstsein ohne die traditionelle
exegese die aber die über jahrhunderte
lang dadurch gelaufen sind
natürlich finden sie kriegerische
[Musik]
aussagen aber auch historische befunde
die die wirklich auch einen gläubigen
menschen erschüttern selbst wenn sie den
koran aufschlagen finden sie stellen wo
es um bekämpft die leute und tötet und
all diese nahezu inhumane aussagen zu
finden sind nur die schwierigkeit ist
wie gehen wir mit diesen stellen um wenn
wir natürlich so tun als wenn wir sie 11
verstehen dann tun wir nichts anderes
als das was gerade diese
fundamentalisten
aber das ist ja nicht irgendein text ja
der ein mensch sich ausgedacht hat
sondern es ist in der vorstellung ja
gottes wort schwierig nicht also gott
spricht aber beschränken
also ich glaube also gerade sie haben
sich das auf arabisch offenbart genau
also eine sache die der koran sozusagen
eingenommen hat das ist die sprache des
propheten muhammad arabisch gesprochen
das heißt gerade als ein gläubiger
muslim glaube ich natürlich schon das
ist das von gott ist nur das wort ist
aber gutes wort nicht in einem vakuum an
seinem historischen raum sondern
natürlich durch die historie hindurch
dass der ganze kontext der offenbarung
ist der kontext des siebten jahrhunderts
auf der arabischen halbinsel und diese
klasse völlig legitim andere zu töten
weil sie eine frau war so viel wert wie
ein ikea spiel heute ein ikea stuhl ja
kaum was einfach eine wahre mit mit der
man machen kann was man will wenn man es
einmal erworben hat in dieser situation
entsteht der islam und dann haben wir
dann stellen im koran zu lesen die für
ein heutiges verständnis natürlich kaum
zu verstehen sind weil wir von der
gleichberechtigung man von einer frau
aus leer ausgehen sollten also der
horizont des korans aber gerade da ist
die schwierigkeit wie gehe ich mit einem
text einen bestimmten kontext nach
vorgegangen ist
ob diese einzelne stellen wenn es um die
bekämpfung geht oder wenn es auch aus
dem leben des propheten ist um sie um es
mit den worten von einem islam rechtlich
er dämlich zu sagen norman stiftenden
charakter haben
darüber gibt es viel diskurse in der
islamischen tradition und wer würde ich
den teufel tun so seien jetzt ein so ein
pingpong zu betreiben indem ich einfach
auch so in dem schiller des koran da
steht etwas aber das ist einfach keine
legitime art und weise mit so einem text
umzugehen da von vornherein ganz ganz
anders verfasst jetzt schauen wir sie
haben
sie möge mir sein vertrauen dass der
koran ein fragmentarischer eine
dichterische was auch immer ist also
dieser poetischen charakter hat sie
können nun auch fragen warum entsandt
ein gott der etwas von menschen will
einen poetischen text also wenn ich was
von meinem sohn haben will also wenn ich
ihm einfach einen befehl geben was
machen
ich werde ihm doch keine wilke gedicht
vortragen ich werde ihm ganz genau sagen
so unmissverständlich wie möglich
deshalb meinen willen vollziehen soll
der koran scheint auch die
willenserklärung gottes zu sein aber
dichterisch poetisch von von ambiguität
getragen offen oft wissen sie gar nicht
worum es geht es gibt stellen
kontextualisierung zeit phänomene
aufgenommen es gibt auch konträre
aussagen im koran selbst die selber
ausschließlich der sprecher
wie gehen sie damit um und all das zeigt
es dass mein umgang mit dem koran nicht
so sein kann wie als wäre der plan ein
werkzeugkasten so dass ich einfach nach
belieben nach hindern werkzeug hole und
mein alltag damit gestaltet sind
das ist nicht der der übliche umgang mit
dem koran der koran muss verstanden
werden und dafür brauchen wir menschen
die was von der islamischen geschichte
verstehen
und da hilft uns nicht glauben so jemand
wie ahmed abdel samad der 1
der in dieser weise mit dem koran umgeht
oder mit der islamischen tradition und
er hat das ganze recht alles zu machen
und noch mehr spam ich glaube ihm fehlen
gerade die worte weil er alles schon
gesagt was er sagen wollte
das ist sein gutes recht und ist schön
dass es ihn gibt und nicht schön ist ein
kollege von mir geben damit den streit
für mich ist ja kein gesprächspartner
also ich finde das interessant sie sagen
es ist gottes wort aber es ist in der
zeit und in der zeit zu verstehen also
müsste man eigentlich sie fragen wie
denn ein koran heute raus irgendwie
hätte wenn er jetzt zb ihnen offenbart
werden
und das ist genauso das heißt wenn der
koran mir heute offenbart worden wäre
wäre würde der koran die heutigen
bedingungen der heutigen zeit aufnehmen
und einer sprache sein die heute ist und
die heutigen alles was heute
kunstprojekt und gegenwerte glaubt trägt
auch aufnimmt das heißt aber wenn ich
heute mit einem koran umgang habe den
ich erstens als das reine wort wird ist
begreifen und zweitens dass ein text
historisch entstanden ist historische
phänomene aufnimmt habe ich ein
doppelter aufgabe nämlich die die
botschaft aus der geschichte heraus für
mich zu lesen
dh es kann keine einzige exotisches werk
des korans gebend für alle zeiten
sondern jede zeit hat die aufgabe für
sich den koran erneut zu erringen erneut
zu so zu interpretieren zu gestalten und
da bleiben und dass das ist so das ist
das koreanische auch sehr vieles
verborgen dass wir nicht verstehen
ich glaube auch diese romantische idee
die falsch romantischen idee wir können
alles verstehen was sie in einem text
ist das dürfte später dreht gezeigt
haben dass sie nicht der fall ist der
koran bleibt auch verfügbar
sie haben eine berühmte stelle im koran
bekämpft die die leugner vorher sie
trifft und dann könnte man ja meine was
steht eigentlich im arabischen dafür
dafür steht die ungläubig oder so etwas
und dann das wort kaffee
heißt so etwas wie undankbar ablehnen
also von einer botschaft überzeugt sein
trotzdem nein sagen
der mann der trotz also leuten er ist
derjenige der von der wahrheit der
botschaft überzeugt ist aber dennoch
nein sagt also eigentlich angeklagt aber
es läuft ja das gleiten genau und so
einen personal welches eltern getroffen
heute nicht oder wer sie eigentlich dass
sie doch nicht einfach schlicht
ungläubiger benötigt als ungläubige
bezeichnet
warum tun sie das warum integration das
gesicht sagen ich bin jemand der einfach
ein ganz anderes konzept sondern von
leben hat und für mich gut spielt
überhaupt keine rolle in meinem leben
man ist kein gut gibt für mich das ist
wunderbar aber ich könnte niemals seinen
leuten haben und ich weiß aber schon wer
damit gemeint ist wenn es im koran steht
natürlich die amerikaner gemeint dies
war von der botschaft des korans
überzeugt waren aber um nicht ihre
machtposition aus der hand zu geben
geleugnet haben
also nicht christen und juden oder
atheisten nein keiner weise aber es gibt
ja auch stellen über christen an die
unis heißt dass ich eine kleine
pauschale feier sind finden kein
pauschaler claire und keine
pauschalaussagen über die christen der
juden es gibt große würdigung der
christlichen gemeinde
es gibt also lieber maria gibt es eine
eigene suche und maria wird als die
beste frau der welt vorgestellt und jesu
natürlich mit allen höchsten schönen
worten und jemanden finden kann
es gibt eine große würdigung aber es
gibt auch eine dezidierte kritik es gibt
genauso jüdische würdigung aber
dezidierte kritiker gegenüber der
jüdischen gemeinde ist ist der
universalen anspruch sozusagen der dort
verloren gibt durch die auserwählt reiz
des eigenen volkes das wird koranische
kritisiert ich finde es auch interessant
dass es im islam eigentlich keine keine
kirche kein papst gibt es niemanden der
irgendwie festlegt was denn eine
richtige auslegung oder der richtige
glaube ist ja wie findet man das als
würden sie so liebt eine richtige
schritt eine falsche deutung nicht wie
dankbar ich bin dass so etwas bei uns
nicht gibt denn das ist ja natürlich
eine unglaublich verklemmen die idee
dass es eine instanz geben die meinen
glauben über meinen glauben wacht und
mir sagt was richtig und falsch ist
entschuldigung ich bin doch nicht auf
den kopf gefallen ist nicht meine
geschichte und tradition befassen und
selbst auch idee nach vorbringen die
gegen alle anderen sind aber solange sie
begründet sind sind sie war die
islamische theologie im engeren sinne
ist eine kontrovers theologie das nenne
ich auch immer alle kann also lange
streitgespräche da gibt es nicht jemand
der historisch monologe führt sondern
das ist immer dialogisch und im dialog
der eignet sich so etwas wie
wahrheitsfindung und das finde ich
unglaublich wichtig nehmen sie einfach
einer der einfachsten sachen dieser
religion alle muslime glauben an den
einen gott
aber was heißt dass an den anhänger hat
wie wir die einheit gottes verstanden
sie haben in derselben zeit elften
jahrhundert vier unterschiedliche
auffassungen die vier unterschiedliche
schulen hervor bringen um zu erklären
was die einheit bereits die attribute
gutes zu verstehen sind und wenn sie
diese ganze kontroverse sehen sie merken
die eine seite ist platonisch geprägt an
der seite so tierisch geprägt ein
anderer seite ist aber müssen jetzt alle
muslime die hat ein bisschen
bildungsferne schichten angehören
das alles wissen und aristoteles lesen
und um auch diese differenzierung zu
verstehen ich meine die haben dieses
buch ja genau
also was ist eigentlich studiert in
münster schon ein münchen natürlich
müssen sie nicht danach es lesungen
platte sind aber worauf können sie sich
verlassen also auch jemand der antwort
nicht theologisch gebildet ist sie
können sich nicht auf ein lehramt
verlassen
seien sie kündigt auf theologinnen und
theologen fahrten berufen die versuchen
einen bestimmten ein bestimmtes
verständnis dieses islam vorzutragen
aber sie wissen wohl das ist nur ein
verständnis aber nicht das verständnis
überhaupt ich meine wer versteht dass
das ist doch egal ob klar da mal
beigebracht wer verstehen
er gibt zu dass ein anderes auch anders
verstehen aber die theologen im iran
oder in saudi arabien sind
wahrscheinlich haben andere
andere lesarten us iran gerade glaube
ich weniger da ist man muss
unterscheiden zwischen mullahs der wie
auch immer die auch sehr gut ausgebildet
sind und dann noch diese anderen das
oder da ist heiliger ist sehr in ihrer
least kann die kündigt mit großer
tradition sehr gut aus was sie daraus
machen ist ein anderer sache aber die
machen auch gute arbeiten also wir haben
kontakte mit ihm
saudi arabien ist für mich überhaupt
keine referenz gegenstand saudi arabien
ist ein land welches alle werte des
islams einfach wirklich mit den füßen
tritt das ist einfach das land was alles
was islamisch heilig ist unheilig
gemacht hat saudi arabien also die kaaba
die ist einfach nicht mehr das was sie
ist
das ist alles ist das ist wie ein
mainhattan mit schlechten geschmack
gebildet dort also wenn wir dorthin
haben wir keine spezielles gefühl
saudi arabien verachtet das recht der
frauen saudi arabien nach dem
verständnis von islam das ist wirklich
einfach widerwärtig das wirst du nicht
niemals sein ein referenz gegenstand
sein wenn man ganze berühren ist gerade
zu zeigen da so ist nicht geht wenn man
ab sofort einmal existieren da wenn er
sagt ja aber das ist doch genau das was
die anderen die fundamentalisten
zitieren man kann ja nicht sagen dass
das nicht mit dem islam zu tun hat in
der tat hat das nicht nicht mit dem
islam zu tun
aber was heißt das denn das heißt ja
dass diejenigen die heute
terroranschläge verüben in barcelona und
der schweiz wo auch gemacht
sie sind menschen die es zutiefst
religiös geprägt sind
aber was sie da inszenieren das ist
nicht mehr religiös das ist in der tat
eine post religiöse gäste die sie da
haben
keiner von ihnen hat ist von demut
getragen keiner von ihnen und zweiter
die sind davon überzeugt dass das was
sie machen die wahrheit ist da vor
schreck ich zurück wissen sie weil ich
denke wer bin ich schon um sagen zu
können was wahrheit ist sondern ich mir
nur demütig zitternd am werke als
hermeneutische konstantem eines
religiösen da seins natürlich versuche
irgendeine korane stelle zu verstehen
und denkt immer noch habe ich wirklich
alle interpretationen dazu gelesen habe
ich sie verstanden kann ich überhaupt
diese sprache erfassen
da ist einfach ein enorme durchsagen
distanz zu mir selbst und meinem eigenen
verständnis gegeben
lassen sie uns noch ein bisschen über
diese schattenseiten spreche jetzt diese
wahhabiten in saudi arabien aber
allgemein der fundamentalismus der so
scheint es mir zumindest nimmt zu sie
haben am 11 september 2001 oder ein tag
danach entschieden islamwissenschaften
zu studieren
warum sie schreiben nach in ihrem buch
osama bin laden ist ein gewächs unserer
zeit
also irgendwie hat das etwas mit der
moderne zu tun mit dem westen zu tun was
meinen sie damit
ja also auch nichts unterschreiben in
western aber überhaupt etwas was
faktisch ja nicht vor 500 jahren gegeben
hat auch diese ganze selbstmordattentate
all das aber wenn das wirklich genuin
rein islamisch wäre könnte man auch noch
fragen warum geschieht das alles jetzt
in den letzten 30 jahren vielleicht und
nicht einfach vor 500 jahren wo die
menschen noch ruhig geblieben waren als
heutigen fortschrittlich und aufgeklärt
und dieser will das ist natürlich schon
so dass diese auch eine im tiefsten
sinne manipulativ sind manipulativ in
dem sinne dass sie den anschein erwecken
religiös zu sein weil sie ständig mit
religiösen parolen bedienen und arbeiten
auf die fahne steht das islamische aber
das ist nur der schein wenn sie denn
genau schauen was sie eigentlich machen
was so was ist der kern einer
fundamentalistischen idee der kern ist
hier dass nichts auf dieser welt wertes
dass es nicht zugrunde gehen wird also
alles was ist ist wer das es so grunde
liegt nennen sie mir irgendetwas was für
die fundamentalisten wert wäre zu
bewahren sagen wir leben nein ihre
eigenes leben nein die kaaba etwa 9
propheten grab nein
in einem statt in einem ort nicht aber
was ist das für eine definition das
lesen sie bei goethe im faust alles was
entsteht ist es während das ist
zugegeben das ist das was mein physio
vertritt nämlich eine höchsten
realistische idee eine militante
michaelis muss wohnt diese gruppierung
im ausblick auf an ihren sites ja genau
deswegen der die dschihadistische hellen
grundidee genau unter dem selbstmord
traurige daran ist dass dieses jenseits
dieser das was diese jenes das ist
überhaupt nicht so gegeben wenn sie auch
kuranyi sehen diese ganze bilder sind
sprachbilder sie glauben doch nicht
wirklich also sie können sagen ja du
glaubst es ich glaube doch nicht
wirklich dass das paradies ein garten
ist das ist natürlich ein sprache
gewisse leute glauben dass es steht der
trend des zu sein ist eine falsche leser
hat ja war schon dagegen wissen sie es
gibt auch bei aller offenheit gibt es
auch vernunft
also sie können wir doch nicht sagen
dass das jenseits seitlich gefasst ist
also wenn das jenseitige das ist was
jeder von raum und zeit ist dann ist ja
nicht das eine einfache vorstellen aber
es ist doch nicht unvernünftig das
zurück zu denken deswegen ist es auch
für menschen die keine abstrakte
vielleicht klein abstraktes vermögen
besitzen da sie nicht sich vorstellen
können was auch im koran steht nämlich
die hölle ist wenn gott sich abwendet
von ihnen und paradies ist gute show das
ist etwas was mich für mich genommen
das schließt auch etwas von sinnen
freuten und von hier aber frauen und so
weit aber zugleich hören sie dass das
jenseits im dass das ist was die
sinnliche welt überschreitet wie kann
das was die sinnliche welt überschreitet
weiterhin sinnlich verfasst sein
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn also per
definition und kleinem sind daher kann
er schon glaube ich mit fug und recht
behaupten dass eine einer eine
verhärtung einem bestimmten jenseits
ideen natürlich die perversion
eine idee ist er es eigentlich sehr
offen und als als vorstellung gegeben
ist
sie haben viel mit muslimen zu tun in
ihrem institut und auch außerhalb wie
stark ist diese dieses vorurteil dieses
bild das wir haben das einige muss angst
haben vor veröffentlichung vor dem
westen auch irgendwie den eindruck haben
von einem dekadenten massiven
gesellschaft materialistischen
gesellschaft geht uns es gibt natürlich
gibt es alles gibt es auf jeden fall
aber zumindest die sagen mir die
bildungsinländer also die fünf millionen
muslime in deutschland oder über 1
millionen oder auch in mitteleuropa
da ist glaube ich nicht so einfach
homogen zu bestimmen also meine
studierende ich habe 800 studierenden
die aus unterschiedlichen familien
kommen unterschiedlich sozialisiert sind
auch hätte nicht an unterschiedliche
unterschiedlichen herkünften haben sie
sind ganz offen sie müssen feuerbach und
kann bei mir lesen sie müssen hat uns
kritik
religionskritik in lesung auch und
islamischen tradition sie müssen
verstehen dass eben diese ganze
hermeneutische ideen da sind dass man
kritisch damit umgehen kann das alles
machen sie und kritik der gutes beweise
bei kann das ist konstitutiv man
vorlesungen und das ist etwas was sie
auch so zum lehrangebot gehört da wir
verstehen dass sie einfach in europa
sind und hier gelten natürlich auch
diese standards die wir aufnehmen aber
nicht unkritisch auch man kann auch
gegen kritik der kannte schon gutes
beweise etwas sagen und doch das wird
zur sprache kommen
das heißt da habe ich auch eine große
hoffnung gerade dadurch ein master
arbeit gelesen von einer generation die
gerade zuende kommend über kanton youm
und al ghazali und die post über die
qualitätskriterien beiden diskurse und
das ist wunderbar ein student der gerade
wald zu der gesellschaften und gegeben
wird kann diese traditionen übersetzen
das klingt nach einem sehr vernünftigen
rational zugang zur religion mit einer
kritischen auseinandersetzung für mich
klingt das ein bisschen nach aufklärung
dass jetzt auch das was der kritiker ob
der song hat eigentlich fordert dass das
man klar zwischen politik und religion
trennt er sagte aber auch es ist
sozusagen der geburtsfehler des islam
dass er diese trennung nicht macht die
sind diese säkulare
säkularisierung und religion und politik
von anfang an zusammen denkt weil schon
in der figur mohammed die geistige und
politische führer ist und sie selbst
sagen im buch für mich überraschend der
islam braucht keine aufklärung das
müssten sie erläutern
ja es ärgert mich sogar selbst auch weil
das ist eigentlich drin haben ja weil es
viel einfacher wäre zu sagen der islam
braucht eine aufklärung und ich bin
gerade der aufklärer der das macht
schauen sie ich bin vernünftig und
angekommen kann gut deutsch und kann
auch kann lesen das würde mir auch die
mehrheitsgesellschaft sehr gut hut
nehmen und mich erheitern und feiern
aber ich bin gerade derjenige der sagt
vorsicht dann auch die aufklärung ist
kein allheilmittel
zweitens auch die aufklärung hier also
eine geschichtlich gewachsenen
kontextbezogene bewegung tief verbunden
mit einer christlichen kritik nicht also
wenn die aufgabe kann ze denken was ist
aufklärung da ist eine klare kritik der
christlichen kirchlichen stellen weisen
er spricht und heizung von feigheit
selbst nicht selbst denken zu wollen
und diese tradition erstens kenne ich
aus der eigenen islamischen tradition
zweitens dass ein vox übernehmen
verkennen dass der islam kein
christentum ist wie sie schon vorhin
erwähnt haben wir haben keine lehramt um
kleine kirche wo gegen solches
rebellieren
wenn sie sagen der islam braucht eine
aufklärung der islam ist doch kein
subjekt denn der islam hat noch nie
etwas getan sondern dass ich nicht mal
die muslime wenn die seinen muslime
brauchen eine aufklärung dann muss man
sagen welche werden also ich brauche
recht keine aufklärung sondern
verbraucht das denn
und dann wird man es nur sein okay
diejenigen die in saudi arabien sind die
braucht man eine aufklärung ja solange
wir mit den militärische beziehungen
führen aus europa und der westlichen
welt und amerika dann wundere ich mich
nicht warum in diesem land nichts belegt
die ganze sache ist natürlich viel
komplexer als wenn ich alles seien
religiös motiviert sehe weil so getan
wird als mehr als nur religiös und nicht
sehe das wirklich politisch und
ökonomisch geprägte bild in der alles
eigentlich zusammenhängt sagen naja
während mir so sagen so diese einfache
trick zionistische thesen einfach viel
zu oberflächlich
jetzt ist er nach barcelona letzte woche
ist etwas passiert was sie
wahrscheinlich befürworten sie sagen man
sollte verantwortung übernehmen für den
eigenen glauben dass heißt nicht
kritisch sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
aber es kann vielleicht auch etwas
heißen nämlich sich klar abzugrenzen auf
die straße zu gehen zu protestieren
gegen solche islamistischen terror
attentat wir schauen uns dazu ganz kurz
alte das wasser nun in barcelona ging am
abend hunderte auf die straße
die muslimischen organisationen hatten
dazu aufgerufen auch hier spürt man das
aufatmen dass die terrorzelle
zerschlagen wurde
endlich ist es vorbei eine wunderbare
nachricht und es zeigt einfach wie toll
unsere polizei ein produkt wir spüren
eine große wut sie haben kein recht dazu
unschuldige menschen zu töten
die demonstration heute in barcelona ein
wichtiges zeichen gegen den
islamistischen terror
ein wichtiges zeichen sehen sie das
ähnlich ich finde es wunderbar zu sehen
dass muslime gerade sich ihr eigenes
recht fordern nicht mit denen gleich
gesetzt zu werden die das alles tun
ich finde es wie gesagt wunderbar aber
zugleich sehe ich die gefahr dass wir
nachdem wir das gesehen haben uns dann
gut geht weil wir denken ach schön die
muslime waren auf der straße wir haben
demonstriert gegen das böse sie habe ich
distanziert davon und meinen dass durch
diese distanzierung etwas geschehen ist
ich meine dass damit gar nichts
geschehen ist allein weil wir auf die
straße gehen und sagen ich habe nichts
damit zu tun ist nichts geschehen
aber es geht darum dass wir positive
angebote machen dass unsere jugendlichen
nicht mehr verführt werden
es geht darum dass wir sehen was habe
ich falsch gemacht dass einer der seinen
namen trägt wie ich gerade so etwas
unglaublich unbedenklich schlimmes tut
dem namen meiner religion die antriebe
die einzige region ist die frieden im
titel trägt also islam wie kann es sein
und da ist mir die verantwortung beide
seiten mussten zu kurz gegriffen dass
wenn die muslime die gerne demonstrieren
sie mögen weiter demonstrieren aber
nicht meinen dass solche demonstrationen
etwas probleme gelöst ist und die
anderen die das eher erwarten wir wollen
dass alle muslime sich von jedem
attentat distanzieren
ist natürlich muslime während der
generalverdacht gestellt und ich weigere
mich so sagen jede woche eine neue
facebook statusmeldung zu schicken
das kann ich verstehen ich war bei der
vorbereitung hat die sendung überrascht
ich habe eine studie gesehen
die wurde 20 13 gemacht von dem
niederländischen sozialwissenschaftler
hut koopmanns vielleicht kennt sich
er hat in sechs europäischen ländern
untersucht wie fundamentalistische
christen aber auch muslime denken und
hat das gegenüber gestellt und dabei ist
rausgekommen fast die hälfte haben eine
fundamentalistische glaubens auffassung
hier sehen wir zum beispiel über 50
prozent der muslime möchten eine
rückkehr zu den wurzeln des islam was
immer das bedeutet religiöse regeln
halten sie für wichtiger als säkulare
gesetze beim christen sind es deutlich
weniger
und auch in bezug auf die homosexualität
ist es überraschend über die hälfte sagt
ich möchte keine homosexuellen freunde
und der westen ist eigentlich auf die
zerstörung der muslime des islams als
das ist ja also wirklich geschockt
wie bringen wir solche ansichten aus den
köpfen gläubigen dass meine frage
schwierig die ansichten aus dem kopf von
dem forscher aus denn es zwei fragen von
ihm sind vollkommen falsch gestellt
wissen sie religiöse fundamente mit
säkularen gesetzen überhaupt vergleichen
zu können ist falsch also wenn sie mich
auch heute fragen würden ist das was
gott dir sagt wichtiger oder das was im
parlament entschieden wird was werde ich
wohl sagen das was natürlich im
parlament in schönenwerd weil was sie
schon gott gott ist die instanz dem
leben überhaupt aber das was religiös
gegeben wir sind ja keine gesetze
gesetzt werden per definitionem talente
im parlament erlassen
nicht der profit macht gesetze das heißt
allein schon das wort gesetzlich ist
falsch wenn sie mir sagen ist das dir
wichtiger dass der koran das wort gottes
ist oder dass in deutschland demokratie
herrscht ich würde sagen ihre frage ist
falsch gestellt
aber es heißt minister einen jungen
muslime sagen sagen sind die religiöse
gesetze wichtiger der säkulare 100
prozent sein und die religiöse aber die
sind in keiner weise fundamentalisten
die frage ist einfach komplett falsch
gestellt aber die anderen drei wären
dann nicht weil
andere 3 natürlich frage ich bin auch
der vergleich mit dem christentum also
wurden jetzt welches christentum wurde
dann gefragt und der tu liegen oder
protestanten sieht die katholische
kirche muss ich dir wirklich als legitim
da werde ich bin froh das weiß ich nicht
aber die die nächsten schon jetzt der
preis ist dann muss man fragen
bildschirm muslime wurden welchem alter
geht da wäre grundlegend wissen sie
genau hier kann man nicht arbeiten der
luchs nämlich ihre frage sehr gern auf
das sein was tun wir was wir tun können
wir haben vieles nicht getan müssen sie
wir haben muslime gerade in deutschland
wenn ich weil ich in diesem kontext her
kommen als gastarbeiter jahrelang
verstanden die einfach hier sind und
irgendwann mal wieder zurückgehen wir
haben gesehen in mehreren generationen
sind sie hier und verstehe nicht leben
dann auch dort leben auch in diesen in
diesem land und dann haben wir gesehen
wie haben sie nicht gefördert die
religion wurde nie ausgelegt von ihnen
selber jetzt hat man seit ein paar
jahren entdeckt es gibt so etwas wie
islamische theologie an den deutschen
universitäten
das heißt was machen wir dort wir
muslime nehmen verantwortung für ihre
eigene religion auf der akademischen
ebene bilden lehrerinnen lehrer aus die
dann natürlich meine studierenden sein
werden die später in den schulen gehen
und dann auch mit besten materialien
dann arbeiten mit jugendlichen mit
kindern
das ist etwas eine ganz positive arbeit
ansonsten die die am meisten über
religion sonst reden haben kaum ahnung
von der religion was wo ist die
religiosität überhaupt übersetzt
deswegen auch ihr vorstoß einen verlag
zu gründen für bücher für jugendliche
und bürger die die religion erklären
denn es gibt noch andere vorstöße ganz
konkrete die gemacht werden zum beispiel
mitte juni diesen jahres wurde in berlin
eine liberale moschee eröffnet ein weg
das zu machen
die politikwissenschaftlerin die
rechtsanwältin seyran ates hat das
gmünder zusammen mit anderen an der
schweizerin sailer keller messahli und
die demonstration stabileren männer und
frauen nebeneinander im gebet vereint
die predigt von einer imam in acht jahre
lang hat artec sehr an dafür gekämpft
gegen den ideologisch konservativen für
einen modernen islam für diese moschee
mitten in berlin in der religion und
vernunft freunde sein sollen
wir wollen zeigen dass sehr viele
muslime friedlich ihren islam neben dass
wir gegen den extremismus sind und dass
wir den islam auch zeitgemäß leben
wollen so zeitgemäß dass die moschee in
einem seitenraum der evangelischen
johanniskirche liegt die nachricht von
dieser neuen moschee in deutschland hat
in der arabischen welt teils heftige
reaktionen ausgelöst
es gibt morddrohungen gegen die
betreiber dass wir angst haben dass wir
angst haben friedlich und liberal zu
leben das ist schon traurig deshalb
sollte die märz gesellschaft sollten die
friedlichen system ist es
zusammenschließen gegen diese fanatiker
unter polizeischutz besuch der
islamismus experte und psychologe ahmed
mansur die muschi er sagt dieses projekt
sei mutig und weltweit wichtig für das
ansehen des islam unglaublich wichtige
schritt richtung reformation richtung
alternativ islamverständnis ist es an
der zeit endlich dass wir auch solche
alternativen haben
auch eine schweizerin predigt in berlin
lh mania sie hat den schweizer städten
gebetsgruppen in ähnlicher form
organisiert jetzt wünscht sie sich auch
für die schweiz eine solche moschee hat
lange gekämpft jetzt steht die liberale
moschee damit beginnt für sie und für
alle anderen befürworterinnen und
befürworter eine vielleicht noch viel
heftige auseinandersetzung über die
interpretation des islam
wie stehen sie zu solchen vorstößen zu
diesem projekt also grundlegend möchte
ich schon sagen dass es sehr gutes recht
von dieser gruppe ist eine moschee zu
gründen und sie können jeder stadt
jederzeit eine moschee gründen oder was
auch immer sie dort machen sie haben das
volle rechte sind freie menschen und
keiner ist wächter der religion gab es
einen saal dahin an
ich würde nicht dahingehend nein das ist
nicht ein ort wo ich mich in die
angezogen fühle weil ich das als eine
religiöse inszenierung empfinde von
diejenigen ich glaube ich habe gerade
eine dame gesehen die nicht einmal ihre
handhaltung richtig hatte
sie hat einfach die haben dort gehalten
wo männer ihr schambereich bedecken die
frauen vornehmlich nämlich waren vor
ihrer brust
das zeigt schon so ein bisschen dass die
dame vielleicht kaum vorher gebetet hat
sonst würde man das nicht machen aber
das ist auch noch witzig wenn sie bei
der moschee schauen auf deren homepage
der moschee erhebt den anspruch es geht
eben eine rutschte goethe moschee das
schon ein komisches größte wird man so
vereinnahmen
aber von mir aus klammern minute er
machen was man will aber eben nur durch
die sand philosoph nicht und keiner von
denen hat jemals wieder wischt gelesen
die haben die adäquate ausbildung dafür
nicht aber deswegen steht dort ja aber
dann leid ist die vision dieser moschee
von rooneys ideen gebildet von einem
anderen mystiker denn ganz anderen
jahrhundert lebt und das was dann kommt
das ist das was bei uns in der küche
hängt also sieben weissagungen von blue
me also sei lieb und eine vertiefte
auseinandersetzung aus dem text ich bin
es sehr schön das ist auch alternative
ideen gibt die gerade einen positiven
eindrücken der mehrheitsgesellschaft und
wenn diese menschen sich dort wohlfühlen
ihre religiosität anerkannt fühlen
großartig wenn es eines dritten raum für
den ist kann ich wirklich mit meinem
ganzen leben dafür stehen dass sie das
machen können kritisch bin ich dadurch
dass ich denke in dem muss doch
eigentlich eine theologische
auseinandersetzung vorher vorausgehen
ich kann doch nicht einfach sachen
verkünden
männer und frauen beten zusammen das ist
eine idee die ich auch in der
prophetischen zeit bereits sehr knapp
und männer und frauen zusammen dass es
etwas sein könnte was vielleicht später
auch sinn macht aber dafür muss eine
theologische gemachte dem zuvor gehen
was du sagen dann so etwas hervorbringen
kann und die leisten sie zum beispiel an
ihren
und viele andere gesund viele andere
auch zum schluss noch einmal ganz
persönlich wie gesagt ich bin ich bin
nicht gläubig gibt es aus ihrer sicht
etwas das ich in meinen alltag
übernehmen kann mitnehmen kann aus dem
islam eine spirituelle haltung eine ich
weiß es nicht
auch schwierig müssen sie der islam ja
vielleicht so etwas wie das der islam so
was anbietet wie dass sie selbst sich
als frage auffassen dass hier leben
nicht einfach so gegeben ist sondern
dass hier leben sie als eine frage
begleitet also ob das alles ist ob das
doch nicht etwas ist was schelling als
unerwartete harmonie beschrieben hat das
etwas doch sich ereignet in ihrem leben
was ihr eigene nationale oder wie auch
die magath dann kalt kunst nicht folgt
das etwas die geburt der kinder so
unglaublich solche phänomene wo wir von
etwas überwältigt sind was was alles
überschreitet und gerade einen sinn
dafür zu haben also einen geschmack für
die unendlichkeit zu entwickeln wäre
etwas was man glaube ich im islam gut
lernt ein geschmack für die
unendlichkeit das nämlich mit sich und
herzlichen dank für das gespräch herr
kein kind findet ja nächste woche
spricht mein kollege wolfram eilenberger
mit vincent hendrix einem experten für
fake news und filter blasen
im gespräch erläutert der deutsche
philosoph warum solche blasen unsere
demokratie gefährden
und wie wir uns vor ihnen schützen
können und jetzt gleich machen wir uns
auf nach china die sternstunde kunst
zeigt ein filmporträt über uhr lässig
den schweizer diplomaten und
leidenschaftlichen sammler chinesischer
kunst schauen sie also rein und genießen
sie den sonntag
[Musik]